jesus
may end up in jail when i say may that's
because he has not been sentenced yet
he faces up to 20 years in prison
because he was convicted on five of the
six counts brought against him according
to the new york times a jury in chicago
found the actor justice moulier guilty
on thursday a falsely reporting to the
police he had been the victim of a
racist and homophobic assault in 2019 an
attack investigators concluded was a
hoax directed by the actor himself with
its finding after more than nine hours
of deliberation the 12-person jury
indicated it had chosen to believe the
accounts of two brothers who testified
that mr smith had asked them to mildly
injure him as part of a publicity stunt
i love that i love that the new york
times has to phrase it this way the jury
chose to believe that you
there was no evidence for any other
account
like justice moliere
literally had no plausible account of
anything that happened
other than what actually was the truth
it wasn't just that the defense had no
defense it was that the defense's
attempts at a defense were so laughably
bad that there was no possible way for a
rational human being to come to any
other conclusion than that juicy smelly
had staged an attack on juicy smellier
and frankly i'm glad to live in a kind
of i think jesse smelly should be very
glad to live in a country where his
attacker is going to prison
i mean it's sad that they're going to be
sharing a cell but it's it's kind of
the best thing that ever happened in the
history of mankind according to the new
york times
mr smilet wearing a dark gray suit and a
blue shirt sat upright in his chair
hands clasped staring at directly at the
jury just after the verdict was read
daniel webb the special prosecutor who
handled the case said afterwards only
made matters worse by continuing to
stand by his account at trial
though that of course is
is very very very true okay so in a
second we're going to go through the
entire history of this
saga because it is so
illuminating about what america's media
life is right now how the elites view
the rest of the country the massive
disconnect between this little bubble of
people will believe any narrative that
casts america in an evil racist light an
actual reality where people like jesus
in american society celebrities who are
double minorities because he's gay and
black they're not treated as outcasts in
american society far from it yeah the
fact is that jesus melies was believed
and cherished and treated as a victim
because there are elites in our society
who believe that everyone like jucy
smellier's victim and therefore should
receive special benefit should receive
special treatment okay and and the
reality again is is very different when
it comes to crime stories from what the
media would have you believe
wilfred riley who's a college professor
who writes for commentary magazine
sometimes really really great welfare is
a black commentator on on race and crime
he says you know the media tried to say
that the jesus
incident as originally narrated narrated
by by justice mode was indicative of
broader trends in american public life
he tweets out this morning but there are
real justice smoothies uh bruh violent
interracial crime involving blacks and
whites is about three percent of all
serious crime and of that three percent
about 80 is black on white
yep but that's not the narrative that
the media are attempting to propagate
and so juicy smoothie became a national
news story with everyone just we have to
believe them even though it was the
least plausible story ever okay it was
it was a super non-plausible story it
was as plausible as the story that
michael jackson had naturally sired
children right there are stories that
just aren't plausible and you can look
at them you can see right from the
outset that they're not plausible and
maybe you hold back maybe you say okay
i'm not going to jump on this one i'm
just going to wait and see what evidence
emerges but our entire media
infrastructure our entire political
infrastructure went into overdrive to
try and use the smoothie
incident as the tip of the evil american
iceberg
and even now the media are trying to buy
this back it's hysterical even now the
media are trying to say well
conservatives this doesn't mean that
that your case is helped great piece
today from jahan jones over at msnbc
titled what conservatives should realize
before they relish the jucis media
verdict oh tell me tell me sir
i wait with baited breath
the actor juicy smilier has been found
guilty of lying to police in 2019 when
he claimed he was the victim of a racist
homophobic attack in chicago bringing to
a close one of the more bizarre bizarre
high-profile celebrity cases in recent
memory says this columnist for msnbc
sommelier told police in 2019 he had
been assaulted by two masked white men
who shouted pro-trump slogans poured a
bleach-like substance on him tied a rope
around his neck but two brothers
abembola and ola bingo usandero
testified that smolette asked them to
stage the attack
abimbola osandero who said he was
friends with smilet at the time accused
the actor of orchestrating the incident
to draw media attention to actual hate
mail he received in 2019. by the way i
have doubts about the actual hate mail
in 2019 even given the fact that
made it a massive issue why aren't
people paying attention to this hate
mail that i received that basically
looks like i signed it
a la bin josendara told prosecutors
malette had this crazy idea of getting
attacked by true trump supporters so he
could post it on social media
some let help throughout the trial the
incident was not a hoax nonetheless the
strange seemingly ever-changing details
in the case have provided nearly three
years worth of material for comedians
and online commentators some of it has
been quite funny in fact as this
columnist for msnbc even more comical in
my view was the predictable conservative
outrage over smilet's allegations
conservatives took to social media in
2019 to express outrage over the drop
charges how dare someone makes a heinous
claim about followers of their dear
leader they screeched violent masked
white guys who shot trump slogans and
used chemical agents to attack victims
many on the right shamed those of us who
knew such a claim was totally plausible
and then the january 6th insurrection
happened yes this is their defense to
everything is january 6 or alternatively
you are so unbelievably full of crap
okay that is the alternative the
alternative is you guys are unbelievably
full of crap there's no defense to the
fact that you fell for this because it
was ridiculous from the outset
oliver darcy over it at brian stelter's
newsletter on cnn is also trying to play
the game where conservatives are wrong
for chortling over the outcome of this
this verdict
he says that it's really bad because
this is this means that conservatives
are going to use this in order to attack
media credibility guys
you don't need any help you've destroyed
your own credibility you are thelma and
louise over that cliff in that caddy
flying okay you don't need our help for
gravity to apply gravity just applies to
you you were stupid enough to buy all of
this you were brian stelton went on air
and portrayed this as fact
and now you guys are upset because
conservatives are pointing out that you
have no credibility and you guys are a
mockery
okay so it's time to go back in time
just a little bit too to the original
jesus story
so you'll remember that juicy smellier
was an actor on a show called the empire
empire of course is a show that is
largely watched by black americans
not a lot of racist whites watching
empire that's just not a thing so judy
smithier was staying in chicago and he
told cnn okay this is this is the the
way cnn reported this story january 16th
2020.
empire actor jesse smithier was attacked
in the early morning hours on tuesday in
what chicago police are calling a
possible hate crime
smolette was attacked by two people who
were yelling out racial and homophobic
slurs and poured an unknown chemical
substance on the victim police said one
of smilet's alleged attackers also put a
rope around his neck according to belize
both fled the scene
took himself to northwestern hospital
and is in good condition authorities
said
as of tuesday evening a chicago police
spokesperson told cnn that investigators
canvassed the neighborhood
where the reported attack occurred and
have found no still images or video from
security cameras of the incident the
only image of smilet police obtained
from security cameras was inside a
subway sandwich shop near the location
of the reported crime the actor was seen
standing alone
chicago police detectives continued to
investigate the serious allegations
according to the pd spokesperson anthony
gulgliemi okay this is the original
report
gaming said detective teams would
broaden their search work around the
clock to look for video on traffic
cameras buses and neighboring streets
okay so the way that the juice juicy
smellier narrated this crime
it was 2 a.m
in chicago in the middle of a polar
vortex it was like
zero degrees outside and juicy was
hungry for a subway sandwich so first of
all this is an implausible story
i don't know a single human being exists
on planet earth who has ever gotten up
in the middle of the night at 2 am in a
polar vortex to go to subway that is
really not credible
first of all no slur on subway but they
had a kosher subway in l.a for a little
while um it's not
good it's certainly not the kind of food
that drives you out of 2 a.m to polar
vortex
but
don't the sandwich will come back into
the story momentarily so jesus goes down
to subway
he's happily munching on his sandwich as
he walks the streets of chicago and
we're we're talking about like kind of
the tony area of chicago okay this is
like the bluest area of the blue areas
of chicago he is he's walking the
streets 2 a.m when suddenly out of
nowhere he's attacked by two red-hatted
presumably mega-added white men white
men
and they shouted him
that he is a that he is a f word n word
f word for gay person n word for black
person from empire
so apparently we have found the only
true trump supporters on planet earth
this is the original story that was
steve as you'll see seems unbelievably
credible by everyone
the these are the only two trump
supporters who have ever seen empire or
heard of empire as it turns out and
there are huge empire fans except they
really hate that there's a black gay guy
in a show that's entirely about black
people
so they start yelling slurs as you see
and then one of them takes a clothesline
and wraps it around juicy's neck and he
begins to fight them he begins to fight
them and then another one of them takes
a bottle of a bleach-like substance and
starts pouring it all over as you see
nobody knows why
doesn't even make any internal sense
this story and finally jesus fights his
way free
and inhib
heroically never loses the sandwich
heroically when he emerges there's tape
now we
fancy when he emerges from underneath
the area where he is being attacked by
these mag i headed
by by by stephen miller and steve bannon
after this happens you see emerges with
his subway sandwich clutched so first of
all just got to say subway is missing an
unbelievable branding opportunity
because if you're a subway this guy
loves subway sandwiches so much that he
is willing to not only fake a racial
attack
but hold on to the sandwich during the
racial attack undermining his entire
case and eventually landing himself in
prison because he loves subway that much
forget jared i mean you probably should
forget jared it turns out that that that
got awkward but juicy as a substitution
for jared
pretty solid stuff okay fine so then
juicy goes home
and he calls the cops and the cops show
up and when they arrive
you see is still wearing the clothes
line around his neck which is an odd
fashion choice
and the police are like can we have your
phone served so we can see your location
and he's like no well that's suspicious
he's like no you can't see my phone
of course because he'd been texting the
two guys that that he that he actually
you know
hired and and by the way jucy is such an
idiot that when juicy hired people to
commit a crime against him he did it by
check
to commit a federal crime
he
signed a to commit a federal hate crime
he signed a check to make that happen
for himself
which is just the best
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang